فمن اعتدى عليكم فاعتدوا عليه بمثل ما
اعتدى عليكم واتقوا الله واعلموا ان الله
مع المتقين صدق الله العظيم انتصارا
لمظلوم الشعب الفلسطيني ودعما واسناد
لصمود اخواننا في قطاع غزه وفي اطار الرد
على العدوان الامريكي البريطاني على بلدنا
نفذت القوات البحريه في القوات المسلحه
اليمنيه عمليه استهداف لسفينه
جينكو بيكاردي الامريكيه في خليج عدن بعدد
من الصواريخ البحريه المناسبه وكانت
الاصابه دقيقه ومباشره بفضل الله ان
القوات المسلحه اليمنيه لن تتردد في
استهداف كافه مصادر التهديد في البحرين
العربي والاحمر ضمن حق الدفاع المشروع عن
اليمن العزيز واستمرارا في دعم الشعب
الفلسطيني المظلوم ان القوات المسلحه
اليمنيه تؤكد ان الرد على الاعتداءات
الامريكيه والبريطانيه قادم لا محاله وان
اي اعتداء جديد لن يبقى دون رد وعقاب ان
القوات المسلحه اليمنيه تؤكد استمرار حركه
الملاحه في البحرين العربي والاحمر الى
كافه الوجهات حول العالم عدا موانئ فلسطين
المحتله وان عملياتها ضد السفن
الاسرائيليه او المتجهه الى موانئ فلسطين
المحتله لن تتوقف حتى يتوقف العدوان ويرفع
الحصار عن الشعب الفلسطيني الصامد في قطاع
غزه والله حسبنا ونعم الوكيل نعم المولى
ونعم النصير عاش اليمن حرا عزيزا مستقلا
والنصر لليمني ولكل احرار الامه صنعاء
السادس من رجب 14 145 للهجره الموافق للسا
من يناير
2024 صادر عن القوات المسلحه اليمنيه